this little red pill is malnupiravir
merck's new antiviral pill
the experimental medication has been
shown to reduce the risk of
hospitalization or death by about half
that's according to one late stage study
of adults with mild to moderate cases
it's the promise of a drug that's easy
to get and take at home that has people
excited you can potentially have it at
home which is
the thing if you can keep people out of
hospital
particularly when they are infectious
because they're they're infected but you
can give them something that reduces
their risks by at least half even in
those high-risk groups you know it's
still thankfully under 20 of people end
up in in hospital but if you can halve
that well and good still means seven out
of every hundred people at risk who get
infected end up in hospital
so how does it work by inhibiting the
replication of stars cov2 through lethal
mutagenesis which is a mechanism that
reproduces the viruses genetic material
to make mistakes this is all about
catching people when they have an
infection and they don't have that
overwhelming immune response so you have
to catch them before that point so that
testing and identification of people is
really critical
and then you have to have a way of
catching the people that don't respond
to that medication
a five-day course of malnupira beer will
cost seven hundred dollars per patient
according to media reports
are there side effects
interim analysis found no increase in
adverse events only one point three
percent of participants taking moleneu
pirovir quit the therapy due to an
adverse event compared to 3.4 percent in
the placebo group still malnupiravir
will need to be assessed in a much
larger group of patients to properly
determine its safety merck plans to make
10 million treatment courses by the end
of this year with more doses slated for
2022 finally it won't replace
vaccinations
which remains the most effective shield
against kovid
you